We're on problem 8.
How many more degrees of arc are
there in 1/4 of a circle
than 1/5 of a circle?
All right.
So 1/4 of a circle has
how many degrees?
So it's 1/4 times the degrees
in a circle, so that's 360
degrees which is
equal to what?
What's 360 divided by 4?
That's 90 degrees.
Right?
1/4 times 360 is 90 degrees.
So that's 1/4 of a circle.
1/5 fifth of a circle times
360 it equals what?
360 divided by 5 which is
equal to 72, right?
35 right.
72.
So that equals 72 degrees.
That's in 1/5 of a circle.
And they're asking, how many
more degrees of an arc are
there in 1/4 of a
circle than 1/5?
So what's 90 minus 72?
That's 18 degrees.
That's answer B.
Next problem.
Problem 9.
Let me draw the axes.
And then they have a curve that
looks something like this
which goes to the origin and
looks like it's symmetric.
It goes like this and
it keeps going.
And they tell us this is the
point minus 6 common 0.
And they tell us-- well
do they tell us?
They have this point and they
say that this is 1.
This is the point 7
comma 6 up here.
7 comma 6.
And they're saying that
this is 6 comma 0.
Although they don't draw a
little point there, which
makes me a little suspicious.
Maybe they just forgot.
Based on the graph of the
function f above, what are the
values of x for which
f of x is negative?
So when is f of x negative?
Well, it's negative
in this range.
From here to here.
That's when it's negative.
So what values of x
are its negative?
Well, at 0 it's 0, so
0 doesn't count.
So x has to be greater than 0.
Because we can't count 0,
because at 0 the function is
actually 0 and we want to know
negative and 0 isn't a
negative number.
And what does x have
to be less than?
Well this is point 6.
So x has to be less than 6.
So that is choice B.
Not too hard, huh?
You just had to say, when does
it dip below the x-axis?
Well when x is between
0 and 6.
Next problem.
Let me switch colors.
In the figure above-- oh what do
I have to draw-- the figure
above shows the dimensions of
a pedestal constructed of 4
layers of marble.
Each layer is a rectangular
solid that is 1 foot high and
has a square base.
How many cubic feet of marble--
yes I have to draw
this-- so at the top I have
cube that looks like that.
It's 1 by 1 by 1, then they
have another marble-- that
looks like this.
It's 1 high and then, of
course, it's 2 wide.
Right, so let's just start doing
the volumes immediately.
The volume of the
top one is 1.
The volume of the second
one is what?
It's 2 by 2 by 1.
It's 2 times 2 times
1 which equals 4.
The volume of the next
one is what?
It goes out like this.
It's 3 by 3 by 1, right?
So what is its volume?
3 by 3 by 1.
So it equals 9.
I think you start seeing
the pattern here.
And then finally we have
the fourth one.
The fourth one looks
like that.
I'm not going to draw it fully,
you get the point.
It's going to be 4 by 4 by 1.
Which is equal to 16.
So the volume of all of them
combined is 1 plus 4 plus 9
plus 16 that's 5
plus 9 plus 16.
14 plus 16.
That equals 30 and
that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem 11.
If x and y are positive integers
and 4 to the 2x is
equal to 2y, what is
x in terms of y?
Whenever you see something like
this-- when you see a 4
and a 2-- just convert them
all to the same base.
So how do you write 4 as 2 to
some power is 4, right?
How do you write 4 as an
exponential expression with 2?
My brain is malfunctioning.
Well that's the same thing
is 2 squared, right?
So that's 2 squared times 2 to
the x is equal to 2 the y.
And we add exponents when
we multiply two numbers
with the same base.
So that's 2 to the 2 plus x is
equal to y-- sorry is equal to
2 to the y.
So 2 plus x must equal y.
And they do this all the time
on the SAT so you should
really-- these are easy problems
if you just remember
to do this and remember
exponent rules.
And they want x in terms of y.
So subtract 2 from both sides.
You get x is equal
to y minus 2.
And that is choice A.
Next problem.
Problem 12.
If the degree measures of the
angles of a triangle are the
ratio of 2 to 3 to 4, how many
degrees does the measure of
the largest angle exceed the
measure of the smallest angle?
So let's say that the smallest
angle is-- I don't know--
let's say the smallest
angle is 2x.
Then the middle angle
is going to be 3x.
And then the largest angle
is going to be 4x.
If I were to draw a triangle
it would look like this.
2x, 3x, 4x.
4x, not 45.
4x.
And they all have to add up to
180 because they're the angles
of a triangle.
So 2x plus 3x x plus 4x
is going to equal 180.
And what is this?
This is 2 plus 3 which
is 5, plus 4 is 9.
So 9x is equal to 180.
x is equal to 20.
So the smallest angle is going
to be 40 degrees and the
largest angle is going to
be 80 degrees, right?
4 times 20.
And they want to know, by how
many degrees does the measure
of the largest angle
exceed the measure
the smallest angle?
So it's 80 minus 40.
The largest minus the smallest.
80 minus 40 is equal
to 40 and that is choice C.
Next problem.
Switch colors.
Problem 13.
The rate for a telephone call
between city A and city B is
$0.50 for the first minute and
$0.30 for each minute or
portion thereof.
So $0.50 for the first minute
and then every extra minute it
charges $0.30.
So $0.30 for every
extra minute.
So if n is the number of
minutes-- the first minute is
there, so it's every minute
above the first minute-- so
that's n minus 1, right?
If you do it for 2 minutes you
get charged $0.50, and then 2
minus 1 is 1, so then
plus $0.30.
And this is for n minutes--
I'm assuming n is minutes.
Which of the following functions
describes the cost,
in dollars, of a phone call
between the two cities that
lasts for n minutes, if n
is a positive integer?
All right, well.
What did I write here?
What choice is that?
That is choice D.
And once again, how did
I think about this?
If I say the cost of n minutes--
it's a function of n
minutes-- it equals, well
the first minute
is going to be $0.50.
And then for every minute after
the first minute-- so
every minute after the first
minute can be represented by n
minus 1, right?
The second minute-- so 2 minus
1-- I get charged 1 minute
after the first minute, if
I speak for 2 minutes.
For every minute after the first
minute, I'm going to get
charged $0.30.
So that's how we did it.
Problem 14.
I don't know if I have--
actually let me just do this
next video because I have to do
just three more problems so
I might as well just
do a video for it.
I'll see you.